-My next guest is
an Emmy Award-winning
actor, author, performer,
and, as of yesterday,
he is now also
officially an astronaut.
[ Drumroll ]
Back from his trip to
outer space with Blue Origin,
please welcome the one-and-only
William Shatner!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's what I'm talking about!
Hey!
Oh, my gosh.
I'm --
-Oh, my God. An astronaut.
We're not really.
You know, astronauts really --
they go up and they do things.
We're half astronauts.
-No, no, no. Half astronauts.
Astronauts. Thank you.
Yeah.
William,
I'm so happy to see you.
And I really wanted to
talk to you.
This is so exciting for me,
because I loved it so much.
And I'll tell you why
I loved it.
One is because, obviously,
you spent a majority of
your life talking about space
and, you know, "Star Trek,"
and you're Captain Kirk.
Here's why I really loved it.
You come down.
You land in this desert thing.
You come out of the capsule.
Jeff Bezos comes over.
Then he comes in with champagne,
and he's like, "Whoo-hoo!"
And you go, "No.
Hey. No.
Abs-- No, not now, buddy.
Absolutely not.
I don't want the champagne.
I've got to think about
what just happened."
-Well, you know, the whole
effect of going into space
and seeing what
very few people have seen,
and there is
no frame of reference.
How do you
describe weightlessness?
How do you describe seeing
palpable darkness,
blackness of space,
where there is no filter of
dust or dirt or
reflections of light?
It's there.
It's like hanging there.
It's evil.
It seems like the monster.
And then you look down
and you see this precious thing,
this warm, nurturing Earth.
And you see death and life.
And you descend
and then you're overwhelmed by
the possibility of the Earth
ending in a short while.
And your life is
in front of you.
But the message is interesting.
The message is,
we all need a wake-up call
every so often in our lives
where your life
is threatened by something.
You may have a near accident
or somebody you love has died.
And, all of a sudden, you look
at your life and you say,
"Wait a minute.
What's important here?"
And you have that wake-up call
and you need it every so often,
because then, you know, coming
and telling jokes
is very important, and you lose
sight of the fact that,
yes, that's important,
but what is
equally and perhaps more
important is caring, loving.
The planet is
going to be inundated
unless we do something about it.
I mean, really bad, and we got
to do something about it.
And what are
we going to do about it?
And what am I going to do
with my life?
And so all the deep things that
we should be thinking about,
every so often,
we need to be reminded.
And that moon shot,
that thing -- that did it to me.
And I was overwhelmed by
all the things
we need to do
and the loves and the losses.
It was an enormous moment for me
that I never expected.
I, too, have an album called
"Bill" that out's there,
and there is a song on there,
"So Far From the Moon,"
a time in my life when they
walked on the moon,
and I was so far from it.
And here I was, 50 years later,
so close to the moon.
And it was
very meaningful to me.
-The album, by the way,
which I just listened to --
it's getting great reviews,
and I love it.
I go, "Wow, William Shatner
has a new record."
It is getting great reviews.
I loved it.
I know you that were saying,
in interviews before
you did this trip,
that you going to write
a song about this.
Are you still
going to write a song?
And has the song changed?
-Thank you, Jimmy.
The other part of that,
the other astonishing part,
was that Dan Miller and
"Rob the Poet" and I
have worked on this album,
and it's a beautiful album.
It's a work of love.
And, as you said, it is getting
astonishing reviews.
We met in New York a few days
ago and said, "You know,
we've got to write a song
about Bill
going up into space.
And what's the song about?"
And we started talking about
what it's going to be
like, you know,
the blue orb
and the thing you see.
I called Rob the Poet
when I came down
and I said, "Toss out
everything we talked about.
Going up there
and having that experience
is nothing like
what you hear about."
-I just want to say also,
on behalf --
I just -- I thought it
was great that you did it.
I think it was also --
maybe also a wake-up call
for all of us to just,
when you get a chance,
just tell someone you love them.
So -- Yeah.
-And that's the --
-We love you, buddy.
William Shatner, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-He went to space!
He's an astronaut.
He's returned.
It's William Shatner!